hello and welcome to this video what's
going on here
GM your chick this guy usually is
generated a lot higher and usually kicks
my butt oh this doesn't look good yeah
why is why what does he have such a low
rating okay check what variation for for
variety's sake is the right way to
express it playing the carom oh my dad
landing should be okay here in the
Braunstein
[Music]
I have the slightly worse spawn
structure but it is not a big deal
usually it was okay I have most policy
on on light squares and let's see I
think I I think the Jeep horn is
something that I can attack I mean it
does not feel very realistic to like to
hope to win this pong but I can at least
put some pressure there Knight f6 on I'd
be sick Knight b6 actually was
interesting that would have forced the
knight trade man maybe not maybe maybe
not I mean a4 was hanging so he has a
hard time to move the knight but okay
that's it's already a thing of the past
he now has to do something here so g4 is
not easily played not quite sure why
doesn't really have much much many ideas
here
[Music]
95 maybe ok so what am i doing Linnea
something flexible so he brings the King
around to cover this yeah what I'm
wondering
Ross or is what's going on here with the
night can I bring the night to differ
night each file is coming though
maybe I'm so I still go for the trade
him it's hard for now not to change late
for his hanging okay and I yes Bishop f4
now I don't think I have to bed a bishop
anymore I think this is roughly equal
ish roughly equal if we just look at the
Bishop's strength the position also is
equal ish but yeah one can try I'm a
little bit more active currently which
which could just be very temporal
temporary thing but let's do this maybe
five I wonder if this is it interesting
to play upon here
I wonder maybe I'm doing too much you
should just stay okay I'm not
threatening all that much with with this
maybe he's taking and then entering with
the rook no I can't go in for now don't
know if this is anything but maybe the
Sun for a pin now we cannot okay so
let's get c5 on the way
if he goes f4 I have you for Cathy as it
was possible but I thought at foreign
King at five would be would be nice
check let's do it thing is he can never
really tell I think he cannot take one
e5 later as I have grouped III which
will be powerful I don't know what he's
thinking about he cannot go forward you
know if he takes a recapture and now I
had each for invasion time let's do it
check
check I'm making real progress in this
ending so what happens here um if I go
ahead sorry Eddie King d3 rook is sex
she said look f6 King III not sure
I cannot leave I go there look who is
six which is seven rook f6 King is some
I'm not sure I'm promoting they're
really not okay let's play the
conservative move
hmm doesn't that win threatening f2 now
whoa what maybe it was lost anyway but
no I'm promoting quite resigned yeah I
was a bit better in this ending a little
bit at least and somehow it didn't it
went slightly downhill Oh maybe we look
at this ending a little bit before there
wasn't that much going on yeah I mean
this must be roughly equal still I mean
I'm more active but okay the engine is
already thinks it's noise there's King
d5 it always wants to play yeah maybe
[Music]
yeah he never took it you know that and
now I mean after that I'm definitely
better right yeah you should check me
just a chance really a bit annoying he
cannot go up yeah this is this is
checkmate so he has to go back and now
this is this is really not easy now if
he takes it this is going to be really
awkward him something why invasion time
on g3 but and this simply is good it's
completely passive for why he has to
play move like that and now okay the
computer wants to play eight five yeah
you can maybe play for the super funny
if you play and move like that it would
be difficult for him to to do anything
and after age form the enemy wants to go
a form that's probably impossible even
here check you know it's better to play
a five to have the g4 square so if White
was aged for this
I think now if you checks me yeah I can
go here and I have g4 which is very
important it's very important now why
this this is a critical position ready
for white I think I'm a lot better now
check check
yeah no I couldn't quite couldn't quite
make this work okay King III
oh yeah but I wanted to really hit a
really promote now I was thinking this
and okay I'm winning all the pawns him
[Music]
yeah this was more conservative but the
idea is basically now f3 or Luke g7 and
then f3
I mean after b5 what he played I think
it's definitely over probably not
according to the engine but it's hard to
believe that he should save this okay
this does lose have it let's say he goes
back I go here how is that not a win I
mean he cannot move any of his pawns and
I'm extremely active Kim Ji Won
[Music]
wow that looks bad
I mean this is this is what the engine
gives but you know really enough
check-check thing like this it's not
clear that I'm winning it looks looks
great it could be wrong
yeah okay anyway at the end he basically
allow me to remote okay guys thanks for
watching